the long-awaited wastelanders update
comes with a number of changes
improvements and new content with that
in mind you might be asking yourself
should I give fallout 76 another shot
fortunately I've put in 30 hours to help
you answer that very question but before
we dive in I went to answer some burning
questions you probably have about
fallout 76 and its current state first
up this fallout 76 feel like a fallout
game now I will dig more into this later
in the video but the short answer is
kind of the branching quest dialogue
choices and factions bring back warm and
fuzzy memories of Fallout 3 and new
Vegas but the multiplayer seems even
more out of place than it did before if
you've already played a decent amount of
76 you might be wondering if you should
start a new character
honestly this one's kind of up to you
the meat of wastelanders story requires
you to be level 20 but if you're like me
and only played a few hours back when
the game came out in November 2018 it's
probably worth starting fresh and of
course is fallout 76 still buggy yes it
is
it's in a better state than it was at
launch but in the 30 hours I've played
I've personally experienced numerous
crashes broken AI and unresponsive
enemies to name a few when we add in the
crashes and bugs my squad ran into it's
a pretty lengthy list I think I just
crashed I think I just hate to be
surprised because you're up you're
floating oh yeah finally how are those
microtransactions
they are still pretty blatant now I wish
I could say that the microtransactions
are only for cosmetics but that's not
entirely true weapon repair kits which I
found very useful can only be acquired
from the atomic shop you can find
improved weapon repair kits in the world
but after 30 hours I've only found one
now with that out of the way let's talk
about the opening hours of fallout 76
wastelanders
as I mentioned before I decided to start
a new character for a couple reasons
first I wanted to see if the
wastelanders update treated new players
differently second the last time I
played fallout 76 was also the first
time and I don't remember a single thing
about it or the character I created once
you've finished the tutorial and exit
vault 76 you'll meet your first pair of
NPCs whoa whoa just a friend here not a
threat these characters will hint at the
overall narrative but more importantly
you'll have the chance to experiment
with new dialogue mechanics the first
thing you'll notice is that the dialogue
system is more in line with fallout 3
and new Vegas instead of the limiting
conversation wheel from four there's a
familiar text box at the bottom with
multiple responses and more importantly
skill checks this means that not only do
your special points contribute to the
number of perk cards you can equip but
they also play a role in conversations
if you invest heavily in charisma then
you can smooth talk your way through
certain discussions conversely if you
decide to invest heavily in strength you
can intimidate NPCs in departing with
their valuables or relinquishing
important information the first story
arc which involves helping out a nearby
tavern called the wayfarer offers a good
introduction to the story and dialogue
mechanics
after getting to know Dutchess and a few
of her patrons she'll ask you to deal
with some bandits that have been giving
her a hard time in true fallout fashion
you can decide how you want to deal with
them you can do a bit of research by
chatting up the locals you can
sweet-talk your way in and convince them
to leave or you can gun them all down
like yours truly some dialogue even
hints at the possibility of joining up
with these bandits I didn't try this out
personally but I'd be curious to see
where that takes the player now I will
say a lot of these early quests are a
bit straightforward when you compare
them to the likes of Fallout through
your new Vegas but it's comforting to
see and interact with all these NPCs the
world feels more alive and it's way
easier to get invested in the story this
time however before I say too much there
is one huge caveat though I think it's
safe to say that a lot of people either
fell off or never picked up fallout 76
due to its online multiplayer
I was definitely one of those people
while the idea of exploring Appalachia
with a friend or two sounded novel the
execution was rough a
fortunately with wastelanders
multi-player feels even more out of
place talking to NPCs reading quest
information and making important
decisions is a lot tougher when your
teammates are talking in your ear it is
but no it is it's it's what's it called
the green green something whenever I
joined up with friends I tended the tuna
NPC dialogue and skip through important
conversations whenever they started to
drag on it's kind of a shame too because
I was genuinely interested in some of
the characters and what they had to say
now even if you don't care about the
characters in dialogue it's still very
difficult to play weigh sling their
story with a team because you can't
complete story missions and another team
members instance this means that if you
want to progress through the story at
pace with a friend you'll have to enter
mission areas like caves and buildings
on your own you can still join your team
leader if you'd like but you won't be
able to talk to key characters and
collect important objects needed to
advance the story with all that in mind
I recommend playing wastes lenders by
yourself and saving the side quests and
events for when you're with friends and
if you plan on starting a new character
you'll want to do a lot of events in
side quests because after you finish the
wayward story arc you'll need to at
level 20 to progress any further I have
an important mission but you're just not
ready it's too dangerous
I can't in good conscience send you on
it at this point in my adventure I
decided to retrace my steps and continue
fall at 76 is original story which tasks
you with following overseer logs this is
where fall at 76 started to feel more
like well fall at 76 I had to grind out
12 more levels in order to continue and
without NPC based quests I found myself
listening to a lot of audio logs
clearing out camps and partaking in
events this meant a lot of combat and
when all you're doing in fallout 76 is
combat it can be a tough game to enjoy
the aiming is still stiff the menus are
just as cumbersome as before melee
weapons feel floaty and there are still
plenty of bugs
it also doesn't help that most of the
enemies just rush you so I feel like my
go-to strategy is to just backpedal and
shoot that's is a good alternative to
aiming but you can't rely on it all the
time since it's tied to your action
points now I know I said multiplayer
doesn't quite fit in with wastelanders I
would recommend playing with friends
when you're grinding out these levels I
honestly don't think I would have made
it if I was playing by myself the entire
time I will say though to fallouts
credit I did find the world a lot of fun
to explore there are interesting
landmarks to visit colorful areas to
explore and plenty of Secrets to find
despite all these bugs and issues I ran
into I didn't feel like I was wasting my
time when you finally hit level 20
wastelanders starts to open up more the
faction system is introduced along with
2 factions the settlers and the bandits
which admittedly sound way more generic
than what I've come to expect from
fallout but we'll look past that for now
you can also visit their respective
settlements here you can rest it ends
talk to NPCs do some shopping and pick
up quests while these settlements don't
have as much character as something like
Megaton or Novac it's still great to
finally see towns in this game just like
previous Fallout games you will have
various opportunities to aid or ignore
one of the two factions and that will
affect your overall standing major story
beats are tied with which faction you
side with and the leaders you befriend
I've only completed a few quests for the
factions so far but as of now the
bandits seem way more interesting their
leader meg is an irreverent
tough-as-nails bandit who dunks on you
whenever she can I know enough about
people to know they've all got an agenda
but for most that's looking out for
number one
meanwhile the leader of the settlers
page is just kind of boring I'm curious
to see how their stories develop as I
play but right now the settlers feel
kind of one-dimensional and if you want
to kick us out then the answer is no if
the walls weren't already kind of a
statement to that effect now I will say
the faction system as a whole feels a
little shallow but I don't necessarily
think that's a bad thing like I said
before if you plan on playing this game
with a few friends it can be tough to
follow the game's story and carrot
throwing another faction into the mix
might complicate things even more and if
you plan on playing solo like me there's
still enough there to chew on so with
all that out of the way does fallout 76
feel like a fallout game now well I
guess it depends on what a fallout game
is to you if you're in it for the story
characters and tough decisions then yeah
all that stuff is there are the story
and characters as interesting as in
previous games wastelanders certainly
has its moments but if you're expecting
the depth and complexity of fallout
through your new vegas then I would
lower your expectations while
wastelanders may not be a game changer
it certainly breathes life into a game
that needed it if you can look past the
bugs the rough around the edges gameplay
and the blatant monetization then yes
there is a lot of fun to be had in
Appalachia anyway let me know what you
think have you been playing fall at 76
are you enjoying it let me know in the
comments below and keep an eye out for
our updated review on GameSpot calm
[Music]